[MUSIC PLAYING]
So by now you know
that there is a lot
of things that go into
rendering a frame on Android.
And when frame rate
starts to suffer,
top priority is
figuring out which
thing has gone off the rails.
My name is Colt McAnlis.
And in order to
help you track down
where your frame
problems are coming from,
the M release of Android has
updated its GPU profiling tool.
Now if you recall, back
in season one of Android
Performance Patterns, we talked
about the profile GPU tool
along with the three phases
of rendering pipeline
that it measured--
recording a display list,
submitting it to the GPU,
and waiting for the GPU
to finish its work.
But let's face it.
Things are a little
bit more complex
than that, which is why, in
the M release of Android,
this tool has been
expanded to show you
eight different sections
of your rendering frame,
conveniently and
uniquely colored
for easy identification.
Now, you're already familiar
with the first three phases
here as update,
execute, and process.
We talked about those before.
They still report
the same information.
So we're pretty much
good to go here.
More interesting are some
of the new stages that
haven't been reported before.
Firstly is Sync & Upload.
This value generally
measures the time
it takes to upload bitmap
information to the GPU.
A large graph segment
here means that your app
is spending a lot
of time doing that,
like if you suddenly
grab 50 new thumbnails
or you're uploading
an 8 megapixel image.
Shrinking this bar
usually means things
like reducing the
number of visible images
or reducing and resizing large
images before uploading them
to the GPU.
Of course, then there's
Layout and Measure phase,
which report exactly what you'd
expect-- the amount of time
spent per frame executing on
layout and on measure callbacks
in your view hierarchy.
High values here indicate that
you have a super complex view
hierarchy.
And thus performing lots
of measure and layout
phases across a bunch of views.
Or you might be the
victim of things
like double taxation in the
wrong spots in your view
hierarchy.
And shrinking this
bar means doing
stuff we've already talked about
like reducing view hierarchy
complexity and using view
objects that can reduce
the chances of double taxation.
Next is the Animation
phase, which
just shows how long it took to
evaluate all the animators that
were running that frame,
the most common of which
being things like
object animator,
view property animator,
and transitions.
If this number is high--
like above 2 milliseconds
or so-- check to see if your
app uses any custom animators
or if some unintended
work is happening
as a result of your
properties being updated.
I mean, you'd hate to
end up in a situation
where updating a property
causes a pause due to disk
I/O every frame or
something like that.
And then, of course,
there's Input Handling.
This basically measures
how long the application
spent handling input events
or, perhaps more accurately,
how long the application
spent executing your code
inside an input event callback.
If this number is
high, this indicates
that the app is spending a
long time processing the user's
input, meaning that you might
want to offload or optimize
that work to a different thread.
And finally, there's Misc
Time and Vsync Delay.
If you've ever seen the
logs from Choreographer
about, like, (DEEP VOICE) missed
vsync by blah, blah, blah,
skipping, blah, blah, blah,
frames, that's that this thing.
Basically, it's the
stuff that might
be occurring on the UI thread
between two consecutive frames
of rendering.
If this value is
high, chances are
you've got some callbacks
and tents or other work
happening that might be ideal
to push off to another thread.
But with all these colors
crammed together on the screen,
it's a little tough
to make out which
ones are causing the problem.
That's why, if a frame
spikes above the 60
millisecond threshold,
you'll notice that its bar is
drawn more opaque.
And it's wider than
the bars around it.
This will hopefully make it
a little easier on your eyes
to pick out.
See, as the platform evolves
and developers get more skilled,
it's only natural that the tools
will evolve alongside it, which
is why you should check out the
rest of the Android Performance
Patterns content so you can
stay up to date with the latest
performance tools.
And don't forget to join the
Google+ community to get advice
from other great engineers.
So keep calm, profile your
code, and always remember,
perf matters.
[MUSIC PLAYING]